zahlreiche wissenschaftler und
unternehmer warnt vor künstlicher
intelligenz kurz ki allen voran ihren
masken stephen hawking ihre maske waren
sogar vor dem schreckensszenario
marodierender und menschen mordender
roboter die hacker community steht jetzt
in den startlöchern um sich im notfall
gegen einen solchen angriff zu wehren
welche risiken uns demnächst rohn ob
diese befürchtungen den anfang vom ende
der menschheit bedeuten könnten und wie
die hacker gemeinschaft gegen kämpfen
will jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen künstliche
intelligenz ki die uns schon bald
haushoch überlegen ist sie uns eventuell
kontrolliert manipuliert und sogar
regiert das war wohl mit das top-thema
auf dem 34
chaos communication congress ende
dezember in leipzig hacker aus aller
welt und wissenschaftler und
journalisten und interessierte haben
sich hier getroffen um über
selbstlernende maschinen zu beraten und
bei einem punkt sind sich wohl alle
einig ki und deren unter bereiche wie
das die learning oder maschinen learning
durchziehen schon jetzt fast alle
bereiche unseres lebens wir haben ja eh
schon öfter mal das stichwort die
burning gehabt mit hilfe einer riesigen
menge an daten und beispielen bringen
sich maschinen selbst bei was zu tun ist
eine künstliche intelligenz also die
allmächtig ist in der medizintechnik dem
militär und auch der
automobilentwicklung ist genau das grab
der heiße shit und nicht nur auf dem
hacker kongress in leipzig ist die
zunehmende skepsis und in gewisser weise
auch furcht vor einer übermächtigen ki
ein zentrales thema sondern auch in
anderen bereichen der wirtschaft der
politik und der forschung
die große frage die über allem steht
wird die ki uns irgendwann mehr schaden
als nutzen wird sie uns menschen bald
haushoch überlegen sein wird sie
vielleicht sogar zur größten gefahr der
menschheit tatsächlich vorstellbar sagt
beispielsweise der britische science
fiction autor charles stroß anlässlich
des hacker treffen sind leipzig er warnt
vor systemen die darauf trainiert werden
propaganda im netz
beispielsweise von staatlicher seite aus
machine learning basierte systeme
könnten zu dem video oder audio material
fälschen oder aber auch darauf abziehen
internet user durch gezielte reize so zu
manipulieren dass sie psychisch kaum
mehr in der lage sind von der virtuellen
welt in die reale welt zu wechseln seine
worte bevor eine ki zu solchen dingen in
der lage ist müssen wir dringend
strategien entwickeln damit sie uns
damit nicht über den kopf wächst eine
eindringliche warnung doch angenommen
dies gelingt uns nicht wäre das dann der
anfang vom ende der menschheit so
jedenfalls definiert es marc uwe kling
der autor der känguru chroniken in
seiner zukunft satire auf dem leipziger
hacker kongress in seiner vision sind
alle wirklich alle bereiche des lebens
von algorithmen optimiert beziehungen
arbeit und die freizeit doch das problem
die menschen gleichen sich immer mehr
den maschinen an und die maschinen
werden tatsächlich menschlicher drohnen
die flugangst haben oder kampfroboter
die psychisch vom krieg mitgenommen sind
das ist natürlich in erster linie
satirisch gemeint allerdings durchaus
auch als warnung zu verstehen nicht
wenige expertinnen weltweit weisen immer
wieder auf die gefahren und nachteile
der ki hin und auch deutsche forscher in
sind darunter zb der ki forscher henrik
meyer und seine kollegin karin ullrich
auf dem leipziger kongress erinnerten
sie noch einmal ein katastrophaler fans
von maschinen learning system die
bereits in der vergangenheit gezeigt
hätten dass sie zitat eine art
geldwäsche für vorurteile sein können in
den usa gibt es beispielsweise software
die einschätzt wie hoch das risiko ist
dass strafgefangene rückfällig werden
und jetzt haltet euch fest also wir
hatten ja schon darüber berichtet werden
damals ich gesehen hat die ki hatte
ausgehend von den trainingsdaten die
hautfarbe eines menschen als
entscheidendes merkmal dafür
identifiziert was sie dabei nicht wissen
konnte der grund dafür ist die
voreingenommenheit der polizei und die
sozialen bedingungen ein unfassbares
beispiel für schlimme diskriminierung
gehen natürlich folglich wenn man
konsequenzen mit sich bringen kann
als ein weiteres beispiel nennt das
deutsche forschungsteam den algorithmus
von facebook der in der letzten
konsequenz auswirkungen darauf haben
kann wie die user die welt sehen denn
der newsfeed werde zwar in die
wer jedoch nicht nach nachvollziehbaren
maßgaben sortieren so lautet die große
über alles stehende frage wie kann so
etwas kontrolliert und verhindert werden
markus beckedahl der den blog
netzpolitik.org gegründet hat zitat wir
brauchen regularien um zu schauen wie
kriegen wir eine nachvollziehbarkeit und
eine demokratische kontrolle von dem hin
wie algorithmen eingesetzt werden
konkret nennt er kartellämter und
datenschutz behörden die den umgang mit
den algorithmen nicht nur bei facebook
sondern auch in anderen bereichen der
gesellschaft kontrollieren könnten diese
kontrolle institutionen sollten dann
notfalls auch geschäftsgeheimnisse
einsehen dürfen eine andere forderung um
gegen eine allmähliche ki zu kämpfen
kommt von der amerikanerin catherine
jamal sie ruft zur praktischen gegenwehr
auf das stichwort lautet etwa
serienmaschinen learning eine kategorie
der computersicherheit die man böse auch
als spielverderber bezeichnen könnte
denn hierbei geht es darum künstliche
neuronale netze zu wärmeren zu täuschen
und auszutricksen auf forscher innen die
in ihrem unternehmen eigentlich daran
arbeiten die weiter zu entwickeln
probieren sich daraus einfach um zu
sehen was möglich ist und die erfolge
künstliche intelligenzen auszutricksen
er waren in der vergangenheit
überraschend erfolgreich konkret
funktioniert das mit speziell
manipulierten trainingsdaten oder inputs
die die ki dann dazu bringt falsche
ergebnisse zu liefern ein beispiel wäre
ein selbst fahrendes auto das
tatsächlich von manipulierten
straßenschildern fehlgeleitet wird die
forschern katrin jamal hat selbst solch
ein experiment gestartet und ein foto
von ihrer person so verändert ihr ziel
die gesichtserkennung von facebook
sollte annehmen sie sei eine katze
hundertprozentig geklappt hat das nicht
allerdings wurde da mal nicht mehr
vorgeschlagen sich selbst auf dem bild
mit ihrem namen zu markieren das
bedeutet also dass sich das programm
selbst nicht mehr sicher war ob es sich
um jamal oder überhaupt um das einer
menschlichen person handelt möglich
gemacht wird dass tatsächlich von einer
menge an open source werkzeugen und
genau die soll die hacker community
die damals aufruf zufolge nutzen und
zwar für gute zwecke
auch der chaos computer club ccc ist in
die debatte um dieses problemfeld
sensibilisiert linus neumann einer der
sprecher warnt davor dass die
ungleichheiten unserer gesellschaft
weiter vertieft werden
er bezieht sich damit auf dem fakt dass
ki hauptsächlich von gewinnorientierten
unternehmen entwickelt und angewendet
wird wo bleiben dabei die interessen der
gesellschaft hinsichtlich freiheit und
gleichheit
man wolle als cc c die ki und ihre
bereiche keineswegs verteufeln dennoch
fordert auch er kontroll kriterien denn
nur so könnten die negativen
konsequenzen der ki zu verhindern sein
und auch der ccc wird ihr handeln
notfalls auch in notwehr
ob sie was damit gemeint ist der ccc als
untergrundarmee gegen ki auf jeden fall
können sich die widerstandskämpfer in so
einem fall auf artikel 20 absatz 4 im
grundgesetz stützen zitat gegen jeden
der es unternimmt diese ordnung also
unsere grundordnung zu beseitigen haben
alle deutschen das recht zum widerstand
wenn andere abhilfe nicht möglich ist
hoffen wir dass es nicht so weit kommt
wie groß die gefahr ist dass erfahrt ihr
immer wieder in videos hier zum thema ki
wenn der kanzler von verpassen wollen
und auch zu allen anderen themen dann
wird man hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht dem genau auf die glocke
wirklich nur dann werdet ihr auch immer
über neue videos informiert ansonsten
greift nämlich der algorithmus ein ja
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken bedroht künstliche
intelligenz die menschheit ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran